si on n'avait pas bénéficié de la
vaccination et du pass sanitaires
probablement que cet été au vu des taux
d'incidence qu'on a constatée dans un
certain nombre de régions on aurait dû
refermer les bars les restaurants voire
peut-être remettre des couvre-feux airs
confiné on n'a pas eu à le faire parce
qu'on dise qu'on dispose de cet outil du
pass sanitaire qui vous savez que la
possibilité d'y recourir s'éteint au 15
novembre prochain donc ce que nous
voulons ce que nous allons proposer au
parlement c'est de maintenir pendant
plusieurs mois encore jusqu'à l'été la
possibilité d'y recourir c'est ça qui va
être proposé dans ce texte de loi
ensuite le conseil d'état va nous
remettre un avis va y avoir une
discussion parlementaire pour échanger
sur ce sujet là